yeah because for people who don't know
like
not all cookie stores are the same right
it's not like like you have to partner
with with people into the various
strategic unique model i said like this
look
and going back to raising money the
reason why we turned down that that 800
mil back in the day is what was mostly
stock there was a good up front don't
get me wrong it was a lot of cash but
most of it was stock
but i decided to raise small right
i raised 20 million bucks
and i'm still working off that same 20
million dollars from that interview and
we stretched it and turned this [ __ ]
into a [ __ ] empire wow because we
decided instead of going out and buying
assets and building from the ground that
would take too long life's short take a
lot of money let's go out then and take
a lot of money which means a lot of
dilution that's why my net worth is high
because i kept my equity right so what
we did decided to do was
let's go around the world let's go
around the country and find operators
that are killing it right now right with
their stores that they have going right
now or with their girls they have going
right now
let's do a partnership with them that's
very rich in their favor for right now
right they keep a majority of the money
coming in right now but we get a roll up
option on their stores we get a purchase
or store in the future right we get a
small rip-on percentage and we get to
have creative control of their
operations so
you empower a great grower in
new jersey give them their exit plan you
give them you give exactly you provide
them with exit plan but you empower
their knowledge and their skills i would
rather work with a bunch of talented
people than have to build everything for
it would take too long yeah it takes
it's a lot so our business model was
find
incredible operators from here to
wherever we're going empower them give
them our genetics give them our sops
make sure we have a great team on the
ground oversee the operation and build
right and it's worked [ __ ] incredible
it's for people who don't know it's it's
it's similar for for
people who aren't really enter into the
weed game would you say it's similar to
kind of like a franchise model nah it's
different it's like uh but you guys get
to curate
who
gets that exclu
cherry pick like i'll go to i'll go to
massachusetts for example you're not
gonna just let anyone get the cookies
brand it would be over it's quality
control involved you go to a market and
you find the best cultivator the best
operator and you go look at all of them
and what they're doing before they even
think about partnering with you and you
you cherry-pick the best and you form a
partnership with them you pick who's
going to do it so it's it's almost like
a franchise idea but totally different
except for you guys get to pick because
you're not going to jeopardize i cannot
the brand because when we think of
cookies we think of uh
the best weed in the world yeah
yeah no it's it's really cool so it's
kind of like a franchise but way
different because no one could just come
to us and say hey we got a hundred grand
let's let's get up nah it doesn't work
anybody can open a quiz nose you can't
open the cookies